so like you just mentioned today I'm
talking about the open team score which
is a project that we've been working on
with the intent of being able to assess
open source projects
and so just for some background at open
teams our main mission is to support
sustainable open source and this takes a
couple of forms on the one hand we
collaborate with businesses to get
finances to support code contributions
and Community Development and on the
other hand we actively support open
source projects that look like reliable
business grade tools now anyone working
in software will probably be familiar
with the basic issue of selecting
Technologies and knowing what projects
to work with and
some of the time that's just going to
manifest in terms of
seeing if there's quality documentation
if the project looks like it's going to
be around for a long time but with
business needs as well there's license
consideration to see if one is able to
do uh that which one wishes with the
project now
with the open team score this is our
attempt at developing metrics for
evaluating open source projects after a
lot of discussions with open source
developers and maintainers and partners
we've come up with some criteria that we
think are valuable and some of these can
be difficult to quantify like assessing
if a project has a good governance model
if there's quality Community engagement
if it has a license that can be worked
with easily and of course different use
cases are going to have different needs
and priorities and so the open team
score aims to assist with as many of
these as possible while trying to
maintain some flexibility
now this isn't the only effort to try to
evaluate open source projects as you can
see there are a number of other projects
as well and I think where we what we're
trying to do really is uh provide a way
of assessing projects in a very broad
sense we don't just look at python
projects we look at
as many open source projects as we can
find and we're also a bit Broad in the
criteria that we evaluate while some of
these other projects focus in on
community or security specifically we
try to have a really broad look at what
our valuable criteria to assess a
particular project
so what this looks like for us so far is
to essentially construct a few different
components that we think are valuable
and right now this looks like popularity
Community security license
permissiveness and versioning now each
one of these we have different data
sources that we pull from and different
data points within and we're able to
aggregate across these data points to
come up with some kind of aggregate
score for each component
and the data sources that we include are
things like GitHub different package
managers Twitter stack Overflow as well
we use the security scorecard project to
assess security
as an example of what these components
can look like for Community we're
pulling in Twitter activity seeing if
there's a lot of questions asked about a
particular project on stack Overflow
whether it has documentation
contributing guidelines or anything in
the repo to suggest there's discussion
of governance and then also some basic
activity metrics like weekly commits
open and closed PRS and issues
similarly for the popularity component
we will look at stars and forks and
subscribers The contributors to a
project the total dependent projects
that a particular repo has and we look
at package manager downloads with the
idea being that we wait to these values
differentially and aggregate a component
score
and to give you guys a taste of what
this could look like we put together a
small sample of 1200 projects and we
collected data for them and scored all
of these projects and here what you're
looking at is numpy now what we did was
for each of the component scores we
converted them to z-scores and so here a
zero is going to be the mean and one
would be a standard deviation above the
mean likewise minus one would be a
standard deviation below the mean and as
you can see numpy of course is a project
we're all familiar with it does really
well in popularity security and
community and it's right around average
for version and license permissiveness
now if I was unfamiliar with numpy and I
wanted to have a look at this then the
first thing I might notice is that I
need to check whether the license is
something that could work with my
particular business purpose perhaps and
then I could see right off hand I don't
need to investigate too much off the bat
to know that it's a really popular
project that has a very strong community
and it looks like it's something that
will be supported for years to come
and so that's kind of just to give you a
sense of what this can look like now
where we are at the moment is we have an
eternal proof of concept we have some
initial metrics and a dashboard and
we've defined metrics for popularity
Community security licensing and
versioning and this is available at our
GitHub repo which you can check out at
that link
as for what's next we have some
continued internal development and
refinement that we'd like to do we'd
also like to have a platform to share
these scores and so right now we have
project pages on the open teams website
and we aim to have the open team score
available so that one can just click on
the project they're interested in and
see the open team score metrics
and lastly we'd like some feedback we
like some Community participation and
contributions
and so
uh if you have questions if you have any
feedback you'd like to give
please check out our repo make an issue
otherwise you can email me or you can
email connect openteams.com
thanks so much
thanks for being here Del that was
awesome I think the the work that open
teams is doing is super interesting and
I think definitely a critical piece of
what the open source ecosystem needs so
I appreciate you for for sharing this
with us appreciate that